Molly and in wrestling it's,
it's still that way.
I was looking at Tj Dillashaw
Liggett, Tj Dillashaw. Oh yeah,
but that's hard to say.
Let's go.
Let's talk about that fight because
I watched that fight several times.
I am of the team. That was
a quick stoppage. Early
startups for sure early here.
Here's my, here's my other point
with that. When there 125 pounds,
you can let it go on a little longer
than if they were heavyweights.
I'd hear more on the side of let
it go long because to 125 days,
it could be a thousand pounds
each in that fight got stop quick.
It's fucking fine.
Especially when talking about a legacy,
it's spending 69 bucks.
How about Tj?
Tj legacy fight.
That guy drained his body to get done.
125 pounds. Hey, don't get
me wrong though, Henry. So
who knows a bad motherfucker.
He probably would've beat him anyway,
but for people that are
paying for the the event,
we want to see some highlight shit.
Definite knockout. We don't want to,
you know, I thought I thought the ref,
whoever he was,
he was just in the beginning.
You could tell he wanted to stop at her.
Like there's guys that they just,
they just want to get in there
and like saved their lives.
He's a really good man. I made a
mistake. Look, it's fucking hard to do.
It's a hard job. I am so glad I'm not a
referee because when they make a mistake,
they can't say, oh, I fucked
up. Let's do it again.
You remember they used to be able to,
do you remember when big John McCarthy
stopped the fight between Marilla
Bustamante and uh, Matt, uh,
Fuck Matlin. Matt Lindland.
Matt Lindland tapped and said he didn't
tap and Big John McCarthy let the fight
continue. Matt and [inaudible]
got him in an arm bar.
Oh Damn.
We missed an arm bar.
That was some serious Jujitsu right
though. We'll see it in the highlights.
Were were Jesus, fortunately just
warm talk. Let's get those nice.
Hey Belle towards got some
fucking high level fights now man.
They are like on the way up
there as close to the UFC,
you can get right. They have the biggest
prospect in the sport and Pico. Yeah,
by far. Yeah. Taking it back a little bit.
What about Conan Sylvia era versus soccer?
Fucking rob.
I remember that Shit.
He redid the fight.
The whole fight got read old school.
They got stopped John too,
and then they decided, you know
what, let them fight again. Big John.
He got hater that Conan
hit Sakuraba soccer.
Our dropped and went down for a single
and they stopped the fight and he's like,
what the fuck are you doing? But it was
in Japan. They pulled them aside in Japan.
It's like wild west,
Bro. You know, like, no.